c'est un examen que les moins de 60 ans
n'ont pas connu le certificat d'études
créée en 1866 il permettait de vérifier
les connaissances de base à la fin du
primaire calcul mental science
conjugaison sans oublier la sacro sainte
victoire et moi au bout de la terre
virgule en émoi au pays des merveilles
c'est monsieur le maire instituteur à la
retraite et qui dictent du passe navigo
il a remis le certif au bout du jour
monsieur au 1er janvier 2018
monsieur lacroix ont été assiégés 7%
ils sont une vingtaine à vouloir
décrocher leur examen pour le plaisir de
la torture alors c'est petit et ola
fabuleux mauvais bonds il ya bien
longtemps il avait fait d'édicter un
passé un excellent exercice devrait
peut-être en faire plus souvent la
plupart de ses anciens élèves ont déjà
obtenu leur certification mire d'une
époque on avait du chant et puis de la
couture
moi qui suis nul en couture ou sur les
sur fils d'anne hurlaient bref c'était
l'anecdote d'apprendre santé on chantait
la marseillaise ventre pour notre
génération c'était le seul diplôme
d'ailleurs mangé pas autre chose par
manche et rapide d'électronicien après
les années soixante dix le certificat
d'études ne s'adressaient plus qu'aux
adultes des candidats de moins en moins
nombreux à votre diplôme il a été
officiellement supprimées en 1981